Gloire à Dieu.
Nous allons, comme je disais, c'est le moment idéal pour revenir dans Ézéchiel.
La dernière fois, nous avions parcouru Ézéchiel, c'était le chapitre 5, du verset 5 au verset 8.
Et donc, je vais profiter, comme ça fait un certain moment, je vais profiter pour faire un petit rappel,
pour rafraîchir nos mémoires aussi dans ce sens.
Ézéchiel fait partie d'une partie du peuple d'Israël qui avait été déporté par les Babyloniens.
Donc, il est déporté, c'était un sacrificateur.
Et alors qu'il se dit à un moment que Dieu les a abandonnés, que Dieu les a conduits à Babylone,
Dieu se révèle à Ézéchiel au travers de visions glorieuses.
Et Dieu demande à Ézéchiel de se préparer à un ministère.
C'est-à-dire que pour Ézéchiel et même pour les autres, ils n'arrivaient pas à comprendre pourquoi ils avaient été déportés.
Pour eux, étant le peuple que Dieu avait béni, ayant vu les bénédictions de Dieu,
ils n'arrivaient pas à comprendre que Dieu avait permis qu'ils se retrouvent maintenant au milieu d'une terre étrangère.
Et Dieu lève donc Ézéchiel avec cette mission de rappeler pourquoi ils sont à Babylone.
Et donc, nous avions parcouru les premiers chapitres, c'était dans ce sens où Dieu lui demande d'être un intercesseur,
de pouvoir intercéder pour le peuple.
Et donc, Dieu, pour lui permettre de comprendre dans ce rôle d'intercesseur,
Dieu va le faire passer par, on peut dire, une école d'humiliation.
Parce que nous voyons un moment que Dieu va demander à Ézéchiel, par exemple,
les sacrificateurs n'avaient pas le droit de se couper les cheveux.
Mais Dieu demande à Ézéchiel de se couper les cheveux.
Dieu lui demande de faire cuire son pain avec des choses impures.
Donc, c'était des choses qui étaient en train d'humilier Ézéchiel,
qui étaient en train de le faire souffrir.
Mais Dieu voulait qu'il puisse comprendre, c'est-à-dire par ce processus,
Dieu préparait Ézéchiel dans son rôle d'intercesseur.
Ézéchiel avait aussi besoin de comprendre pourquoi Dieu était en train de faire ces choses.
Et lorsqu'il parlerait au peuple, il serait beaucoup plus conscient.
Et donc, la dernière fois, nous avions vu un moment que le Seigneur lui avait demandé de se coucher sur un côté.
Et il simulait donc le siège de Jérusalem en se couchant ainsi.
Et aujourd'hui, donc la dernière fois, c'était là, nous étions arrêtés au verset 8 de cela.
Et pour résumer sur la dernière prédication du verset 5 au verset 8,
Dieu avait rappelé à Israël, c'est-à-dire, il leur explique pourquoi ils sont en Babylone,
pourquoi il les a punis. Et il leur dit à un moment que, au verset 5, nous le lisons,
Dieu rappelle qu'il a placé Israël au milieu des nations.
Il avait placé Israël au milieu des nations pour qu'Israël soit comme une ville sur une colline.
Donc, pour ceux qui, je sais qu'aujourd'hui, souvent, ce sont des mots,
mais une colline, je pense que tout le monde connaît une colline.
Donc, si vous voyez une ville sur une colline, c'est une ville, même si vous êtes très loin,
vous allez toujours la voir parce que la colline, voilà, c'est un peu élevé par point d'une vallée, autre,
et donc on voit la colline.
Et donc, c'était le rôle d'Israël d'être une ville comme une colline pour les nations.
C'était le rôle d'Israël d'être une lumière qui éclairait les nations qui étaient dans les ténèbres
et qui ne connaissaient pas Dieu.
Et nous avions lu ce texte, c'était un texte qui nous rappelait,
voici, et c'est là d'où vient la source du problème, Israël avait oublié.
Deutéronome 4, du verset 5 au verset 8, nous rappelle quel était le rôle d'Israël.
Voici ce que le Seigneur dit.
Voici, et donc c'est Moïse qui parle, sur le commandement de l'Éternel.
Voici, je vous enseigne des lois et des ordonnances comme l'Éternel, mon Dieu, me l'a commandé,
afin que vous les mettiez en pratique dans le pays dont vous allez prendre possession.
Vous les observerez et vous les mettrez en pratique,
car ce sera là votre sagesse et votre intelligence aux yeux des peuples
qui entendront parler de toutes ces lois et qui diront,
cette grande nation est un peuple absolument sage et intelligent.
Quelle est en effet la grande nation qui est des dieux aussi proches que l'Éternel, notre Dieu ?
L'aide-nous toutes les fois que nous l'invoquons.
Et quelle est la grande nation qui est des lois et des ordonnances justes,
comme toute cette loi que je vous présente aujourd'hui ?
Voilà le rôle que Dieu donna à Israël.
Et Israël, c'est chaque fois éloigné de ce rôle.
Chaque fois qu'Israël en a eu l'occasion, ils ont dévié de ce rôle.
Et comme nous allons le voir plus tard justement,
c'est quelque chose aussi que Dieu nous enseignait.
L'histoire d'Israël, au travers du fait d'être incapable de pouvoir tenir cet engagement,
illustre aussi, parce que cette loi, ils n'ont pas pu tenir la loi,
ça illustre aussi l'impossibilité pour les hommes d'accomplir parfaitement
tous les commandements de l'Éternel.
C'est une des grandes leçons que nous allons retenir d'Ézéchiel,
c'est que Dieu nous montre aussi pourquoi nous avions besoin du Christ.
Même ce peuple qui avait été béni, qui avait vu la bénédiction de l'Éternel,
qui avait vu comment Dieu avait noyé les Égyptiens,
qui avait vu les dix plaies en Égypte,
qui avait vu la délivrance en Égypte,
ce peuple avait été incapable de pouvoir être fidèle à l'Éternel.
Et ce que Dieu enseignait, c'est qu'il y avait besoin de quelque chose,
c'était que la loi, la loi au contraire, était aussi en train de condamner Israël.
La loi leur montrait à un moment qu'ils étaient dans l'impossibilité de pouvoir suivre le Seigneur
et Dieu était en train de les préparer, tout comme nous, à la venue du Messie.
Et donc, à cause du fait qu'ils connaissaient la loi et qu'ils ne l'avaient pas accomplie,
mais qu'ils étaient allés adorer des idoles de bois et de pierre,
il leur est arrivé toutes les malédictions qui avaient été décrites dans la parole.
Quand ils vont établir l'alliance,
à un moment, Moïse va leur faire établir l'alliance,
c'est-à-dire que Dieu s'est acquis un peuple.
Dieu les sauve de l'Égypte.
Il leur dit, vous m'appartenez.
Israël est d'accord, ils établissent une alliance avec l'Éternel.
À un moment, Dieu leur dit, voilà toutes les bénédictions
qui seront rattachées à vous lorsque vous me suivez,
mais voilà aussi toutes les malédictions qui viendront
lorsque vous n'obéirez pas ma loi.
Et à partir de ce moment, Israël a tout validé, ils ont dit Amen.
Et comme ils avaient dit Amen et que Dieu est juste et fidèle dans ce qu'il fait,
lorsque Israël a eu un péché, la colère de Dieu s'est abattue sur eux.
Bien sûr, ça a été cyclique.
À un moment, ils péchaient.
Dieu a envoyé des juges, les juges les ont ramenés,
ils ont péché, d'autres juges sont venus,
après c'était les prophètes.
Mais à un moment, la patience de Dieu est arrivée au bout
et il y a eu un premier jugement.
C'est-à-dire qu'Israël s'est divisé en deux,
il y avait le royaume du Nord, le royaume du Sud.
Le royaume du Nord, c'était dix tribus qui avaient fait le royaume du Nord
et il restait deux tribus dans le royaume du Sud.
Et donc, la première partie du jugement de Dieu va s'abattre
avec la destruction du royaume du Nord,
qui va être détruit par la Syrie.
Et par la suite, au moment d'Ézéchiel,
nous arrivons donc dans la destruction,
nous arrivons donc dans l'exécution du jugement de Dieu
vis-à-vis du second royaume.
Et donc, Dieu exécute ses jugements
pour que ça serve de leçon.
Il exécute ses jugements
pour que ça serve de leçon aux nations alentours.
Mais il exécute aussi ses jugements
pour nous permettre aussi de comprendre,
à nous qui sommes là aussi,
c'est aussi une compréhension du jour final de l'Éternel.
Ça, c'est ce que nous avions dit la dernière fois.
Et nous avions donc repris ce passage en disant
ce que Paul dit à un moment,
« Ces choses sont arrivées pour nous servir d'exemple,
afin que nous n'ayons pas de mauvais désirs
comme ils en ont eu. »
Il faut surtout que nous gardions nos cœurs
de croire que nous sommes différents d'Israël.
Mais nous devons avoir l'humilité
pour apprendre de leur échec.
Et l'exemple, ça, c'est ce que Dieu nous enseigne
au travers de cette leçon.
Mais la leçon pour les nations alentours,
la leçon pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas Dieu,
c'était un rappel à un moment que la colère de Dieu,
quand Dieu exerce ses jugements,
ce n'est pas un caprice.
Parce que souvent, nous avons le problème que nous avons,
nous avons toujours besoin, un moment,
de pouvoir séparer nos idées préconçues de la réalité.
Souvent, nous appliquons beaucoup,
quand nous disons les mythologies,
nous voyons au moment que le Dieu est capricieux
et puis Zeus décide de faire la pagaille
parce qu'il en a envie comme ça, c'est des choses.
Mais nous voyons qu'au niveau de Dieu,
le jugement de Dieu n'est jamais un caprice.
Le jugement de Dieu est une réponse divine
au péché humain et à sa rébellion, toujours.
Et aujourd'hui aussi, par rapport à cette prédication aussi,
cette vérité centrale aussi,
nous allons nous attarder aujourd'hui
sur la compréhension de la colère de Dieu.
Qu'est-ce que ça nous dit de la colère de Dieu
et comment nous devons comprendre
des jugements aussi durs et aussi pénibles
de Dieu envers son peuple.
Quand nous avons lu le texte,
nous avons pu lire à un moment une partie
où Dieu parle à un moment
et ce sont des choses qui se sont passées
de façon littérale.
Où à un moment, on a retrouvé des pères
qui mangeaient des enfants au milieu
à cause de la famine.
La famine était très forte,
des mères qui ont mangé leur bébé.
Et à un moment, on se dit,
mais si Israël est le peuple élu de Dieu,
là on va parler des nations alentours,
mais comment Dieu a pu les livrer ?
Comment ce Dieu qu'il serve
a pu les livrer à ce point ?
Mais nous avons besoin,
et c'est cette vérité aussi aujourd'hui
que nous allons explorer,
de comprendre qu'est-ce que cela nous dit
de la colère de Dieu.
Et donc, le premier point,
ce sera justement de comprendre,
le premier point, ce sera de comprendre
qu'est-ce que c'est, qu'est-ce que,
enfin on va survoler,
parce que rentrer en profondeur,
ce sont aussi plusieurs prédications,
mais on va avoir l'occasion plus tard aussi
de nous attarder dans la suite du livre.
Mais le premier point,
c'est de nous rappeler des vérités bibliques
lorsque nous parlons de la colère de Dieu.
Je remercie, parce que dans l'introduction
de notre frère Christian,
il a bien rappelé qu'aujourd'hui,
si nous vivons,
c'est très important de comprendre
le prisme biblique.
À cause de notre nature corrompue,
nous avons souvent tendance
à comprendre la colère de Dieu
à partir de notre point de vue humain.
Et souvent, c'est pour ça
que nous allons avoir des questions,
nous allons nous dire un moment,
mais si Dieu est bon,
pourquoi il y a la douleur dans le monde ?
Je pense que ça,
chacun de nous a dû se poser cette question
une fois dans sa vie,
de se dire un moment,
pourquoi ces questions,
pourquoi ces choses ?
Il est tout à fait normal,
il est tout à fait normal
qu'on puisse se poser ce genre de questions.
mais pour avoir une réponse à ces questions,
il est aussi important de savoir
ce que Dieu dit à ce sujet.
Et souvent, ce que je déplore,
lorsque des personnes,
quand je regarde sur les réseaux sociaux,
vont dire un moment,
mais si Dieu est si bon,
pourquoi il permet le mal ?
Ils ne vont jamais à la suite de la réflexion,
ils n'essayent pas de voir justement
qu'est-ce que Dieu dit à ce sujet.
Mais pour mieux comprendre la nature de Dieu,
pour mieux comprendre les manifestations
de la nature de Dieu,
nous avons besoin de voir
qu'est-ce que la Bible nous dit à ce sujet.
Nous avons besoin de ne pas rester
sous nos perceptions humaines
qui sont altérées à cause du péché
et qui sont corrompues.
Donc, une des choses qui est là,
dans ce premier point,
en expliquant,
en parcourant un peu sur la colère de Dieu,
c'est que tout comme les hommes,
Dieu peut exprimer la colère.
On voit plusieurs fois dans les Écritures,
nous allons voir des passages
qui nous parlent de la colère de l'Éternel.
Mais contrairement à nous,
les hommes qui avons souvent des colères,
nos colères peuvent être violentes,
nos colères peuvent être irréfléchies,
nos colères peuvent même être souvent non justifiées.
La colère de Dieu, elle est toujours sainte.
La colère de Dieu, elle est toujours justifiée.
Très important pour nous.
Et le souci qu'Israël avait
lorsque le jugement s'abat sur eux,
qu'ils sont déportés à Babylone,
c'est qu'ils n'arrivent pas à comprendre
que la colère de Dieu est justifiée.
Ils sont juste en train de voir
ce qu'ils sont en train de vivre maintenant,
mais ils n'arrivent pas.
Mais par la grâce de Dieu,
quand nous lisons des prophètes
comme Ézéchiel ou Daniel,
nous voyons qu'un moment,
quand nous voyons les intercessions de Daniel,
nous voyons que Daniel a compris.
Quand il intercède même,
il ne va pas se dire à un moment,
mais Dieu, pourquoi tu permets cela ?
Non.
Daniel dit, nous avons péché.
Et voilà pourquoi tu as permis cela.
Donc, quand nous lisons l'Ancien Testament,
nous allons voir un moment
que lorsqu'on voit la colère de Dieu,
on voit que la colère de Dieu
apparaît toujours par suite
d'un abandon d'Israël.
Lorsque Israël abandonne l'alliance
qui a été établie avec Dieu,
nous voyons un moment
que la réponse de Dieu à cet abandon,
c'est sa colère,
c'est-à-dire la réponse divine
au péché d'Israël
et que les prophètes décrivent
souvent comme le jour de colère de l'Éternel,
c'est le fait que Dieu permette alors
que le jugement s'abatte.
Voilà, la colère de Dieu se manifeste
au travers des jugements
qui s'abattent sur la nation
quand ils ont péché.
C'est une colère qui est justifiée
parce que Dieu, dans son essence,
est saint et ne peut supporter le péché.
C'était bien d'entendre,
quand notre frère Christian a dit à un moment
que nous avons été créés pour le bonheur,
nous avons été créés pour apprécier la joie,
nous n'avons pas été créés pour souffrir.
Mais à cause du péché d'Adam et Ève,
lorsqu'ils ont mangé le fruit interdit,
ils ont entraîné le monde,
la création,
dans les conséquences d'un péché contre Dieu.
Et jusqu'à présent, nous vivons cela.
Donc quand vous voyez des...
Vous pouvez juste...
Aujourd'hui, même avec les réseaux sociaux,
c'est pire.
Avant, on avait juste le journal du 20h
où on avait les mauvaises nouvelles,
mais maintenant, vous avez le journal du 20h,
vous avez les réseaux sociaux,
vous avez les journaux.
Et à un moment, vous lisez,
vous vous dites à un moment,
mais dans quel monde nous vivons ?
Mais nous vivons dans un monde
qui est touché par la chute.
Et c'est-à-dire, quand Dieu permet cela,
il nous permet de comprendre
combien le péché est une horreur pour lui,
combien le péché est une abomination.
Et donc, la colère de Dieu est justifiée
parce que Dieu, dans son essence,
est saint et ne peut supporter le péché.
Il nous a créés dans ce but.
Il nous a créés dans ce but,
mais nous nous sommes détournés de cela.
Et donc, jusqu'à ce que Dieu restaure,
parce que ça a été la promesse aussi,
et vous voyez la bénédiction de Dieu,
c'est-à-dire, il manifeste la colère,
mais en même temps, il manifeste sa grâce.
Il manifeste sa colère en chassant Adam et Ève du jardin,
mais il les empêche de manger le fruit de la vie éternelle.
Parce que s'ils avaient mangé ce fruit,
Dieu qui est fidèle dans ce qu'il fait,
n'aurait pas pu leur retirer cette vie,
mais se rester dans cet état de péché.
Et donc, souvent, nous allons dire,
ah, ils chassent du jardin.
Non, ils chassent du jardin parce qu'ils les aiment.
Et lorsqu'ils les chassent du jardin,
à cet instant, il leur fait aussi une promesse.
Il leur fait une promesse que,
même s'ils ont échoué,
un jour, il va restaurer toute chose.
C'est une grande promesse.
Et aujourd'hui, cette promesse
est en voie d'accomplissement.
Et un jour, Dieu va restaurer
toute chose définitivement en Christ.
Mais en attendant, nous devons vivre
avec les conséquences de notre péché
sur nous et sur la création.
Et si une personne n'a pas la compréhension
de ce que je viens d'expliquer,
il est impossible qu'elle connaisse la paix.
Il est impossible.
C'est-à-dire que si elle n'a pas cette compréhension,
elle va essayer de trouver sa paix
dans les choses de ce monde.
Elle va essayer de trouver sa paix
dans le travail.
dans les loisirs.
Elle va essayer de trouver sa paix
dans beaucoup de choses.
Mais le problème, c'est que ce monde
est tellement friable
qu'à un moment, ton travail,
tu peux le perdre.
Cette personne que tu idolâtres,
tu peux la perdre.
Toutes ces choses sur lesquelles tu te tiens,
tu peux les perdre.
Cette maison
sur laquelle tu te tiens,
où tu as investi,
ça fait 20 ans,
tu as fini de la payer.
Et là, il y a un incendie,
tout disparaît.
Tu peux la perdre.
Mais pourquoi les chrétiens ont la paix ?
C'est parce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne peut pas avoir ici-bas.
La paix de Dieu
est quelque chose de surnaturel.
Et le monde ne peut pas connaître cette paix.
Parce qu'il n'a pas cette compréhension
divine de l'état de notre monde.
Et voilà pourquoi certains vont
se poser cette question
en se disant au moment,
mais pourquoi nous souffrons ?
Pourquoi la douleur ?
Ils sont en train de regarder
la maladie se manifester.
Ils ne regardent pas aux causes
de cette maladie.
Et contrairement à une croyance populaire
qui va...
Alors, on a deux croyances.
Il y a une croyance populaire
qui va idolâtrer Dieu
en le présentant comme un Dieu sympathique
et qui ne juge pas.
Ils vont dire à un moment,
il a jugé dans l'Ancien Testament,
il juge plus loin du nouveau.
Nous avons aussi d'autres...
Bon, bien sûr, là,
aujourd'hui, nous allons plutôt rester
sur cette croyance populaire
parce qu'on a d'autres aussi
où on trouve un Dieu
qui est tellement mauvais,
tellement dur.
Mais restons plutôt dans celle
où on voit un Dieu sympathique,
un Dieu sympathique
qui ne juge pas,
un Dieu qui ne peut pas
se mettre en colère,
c'est incompréhensible.
Nous voyons aussi
que Dieu nous le rappelle,
même dans le Nouveau Testament,
pour ceux qui vont dans ce sens,
nous voyons à un moment
que Dieu nous rappelle même
dans le Nouveau Testament
qu'il reste un Dieu
qui juge.
Nous avons la parabole
de l'homme riche et de Lazare
dans Luc XVI
qui nous le rappelle.
Mais plus encore,
si je vous demande
quel est le passage
que vous connaissez de la Bible,
que vous maîtrisez le mieux,
et même à des personnes
qui ne sont pas croyantes,
la plupart des gens,
le plus célèbre passage de la Bible,
vous vous diriez lequel ?
Jean 3,16.
Voilà.
C'est ce passage qui est
un des passages les plus célèbres,
mais c'est un passage
qui est souvent tronqué.
C'est-à-dire qu'on lit
une partie de ce passage,
mais on ne lit pas la suite.
Et là, on va rafraîchir
nos mémoires ce matin.
Qu'est-ce que Jean 3,16 nous dit ?
Jean 3,16 à 21.
Et vous voyez que souvent,
tous ceux qui vont citer
Jean 3,16 ne connaissent pas le reste.
On s'arrête à Jean 3,16.
Et là, on dit à un moment,
mais Dieu est amour,
Dieu ne peut pas juger.
Pourquoi Dieu ?
Mais non,
Dieu est un Dieu qui juge.
Dieu est un Dieu
qui manifeste un moment
sa colère vis-à-vis du péché,
qui nous montre
combien il aborde le péché.
À cause de ce que le péché représente,
ainsi que ses conséquences,
la colère de Dieu peut être terrifiante.
La colère de Dieu peut être sévère
et terrifiante.
Elle marque nos esprits.
Lorsque les jugements de Dieu
s'exercent sur les nations,
ce sont les jugements
qui vont nous marquer.
Et voilà pourquoi,
par rapport à ces choses,
on va dire un moment,
si Dieu existe,
pourquoi de telles choses ?
Parce qu'à un moment,
les jugements de Dieu sont forts.
Et le but,
quand Dieu permet justement
que ces jugements puissent être marquants,
le but est justement
de nous pousser à reconnaître
nos fautes.
Le but est de nous pousser
à nous repentir
et à compter sur son pardon.
Et voilà pourquoi
la Bible va un moment
nous rappeler un moment
que nous devons nous rappeler
que Dieu,
et ça c'est Hébreu
qui nous le dit
dans le Nouveau Testament,
notre Dieu est aussi
un feu dévorant.
Notre Dieu est un Dieu de grâce,
est un Dieu de justice,
mais notre Dieu est aussi un Dieu,
est aussi un feu dévorant.
Et donc,
nous sommes encouragés
à toujours lui rendre un culte
qui lui soit agréable
avec piété et avec crainte.
Un culte avec crainte.
Il était important
sur ce premier point,
je voulais prendre ce premier point
parce que c'est vrai
que quand nous allons lire
Ézéchiel,
beaucoup de personnes
ont tendance
à se focaliser,
comme je le disais,
sur la maladie du péché,
mais ne regardent pas
les conséquences,
et ils ont plutôt tendance
à se focaliser
sur la maladie
et ses conséquences,
ils ne regardent pas aux causes.
Et le livre d'Ézéchiel
est l'un des livres
les moins aimés
de la Bible.
Quand vous allez demander,
je me souviens
quand on avait,
on a commencé la série,
on a demandé à quelques-uns,
la plupart des frères
à qui je demandais,
ils disaient
qu'ils n'avaient jamais lu
le livre d'Ézéchiel
parce que c'est un livre
qui ne donne pas de joie
à certains,
mais c'est parce qu'ils n'ont
pas compris
qu'est-ce que Dieu
est en train de nous dire
au travers de cela.
Et voilà pourquoi
je voulais aborder
dans cette compréhension déjà
que nous comprenions
au moment que la colère
de Dieu n'est pas
un caprice,
la colère de Dieu
n'est pas quelque chose
qui tombe comme ça
par hasard.
La colère de Dieu
vient à la suite
de beaucoup de moments
de patience,
de miséricorde.
Même moment,
comme il est dit à un moment,
les nations vont apprendre
la sagesse
au travers des jugements
de l'Éternel.
Dieu ne peut pas
laisser le péché impuni.
Il n'y a pas
de pardon sans justice.
Notre deuxième point,
donc on voyait
le premier point,
c'était de comprendre
un peu ce principe
de la colère de Dieu.
Le deuxième point
sera basé
sur cette question.
Pourquoi de tels jugements
sévères et pénibles
envers Israël ?
Quand nous allons
sur le verset 9,
il nous est dit
« À cause de toutes
tes abominations,
je te ferai ce que
je n'ai point encore fait,
ce que je ne ferai jamais. »
Dieu parle pour Israël,
il est en train de parler
d'un jugement
qu'Israël n'avait jamais
connu.
C'est un jugement
qui n'aura pas
de précédent,
c'est un jugement
qui n'aura pas
d'équivalent
pour pouvoir comparer.
Et d'ailleurs,
même Jérémie,
dans l'amantation,
je vous donne la référence
pour lire plus tard
l'amantation 4,
au verset 6,
Jérémie compare
la destruction
de Jérusalem
à un châtiment
encore plus grand
que celui de Sodome.
C'est « quand Dieu parle,
je ferai en toi
ce que je n'ai pas fait,
ne ferai semblablement »
c'est une expression
rhétorique,
mais c'est une expression
qui souligne
combien la colère
de Dieu sera profonde
envers Israël.
Une colère
qui sera profonde
parce qu'Israël
a eu plusieurs fois
l'occasion
de se repentir,
mais ils ont préféré
persévérer
dans leur rébellion.
Jusqu'à présent,
si vous lisez
l'Ancien Testament,
vous allez remarquer
que nous avons
un cycle
dans le livre
des juges,
des rois,
nous avons un cycle
à un moment.
Israël s'attache
à l'éternel.
Dès qu'il y a
une génération d'hommes
qui avaient été fidèles
à l'éternel,
dès qu'ils ont disparu,
Israël se détourne.
Dieu apporte le malheur,
Dieu apporte son jugement.
Les nations autour
finissent par les écraser.
Dieu lève un juge.
C'est-à-dire Israël
reconnaît qu'ils ont péché.
Il n'aurait pas dû
s'éloigner de Dieu.
Dieu suscite un juge.
Ce juge chasse
les nations
qui les avaient attaquées.
La paix revient.
Dès que ce juge meurt,
Israël se détourne de nouveau.
C'est ce cycle-là.
On va avoir ce cycle
qui se répète
même lorsque vous lisez
le livre des rois.
C'est la même chose.
Nous allons avoir
un roi qui craint l'éternel.
Dès que ce roi meurt,
Israël se détourne.
Si l'autre roi
qui vient est fidèle
à l'éternel,
Israël reste soumis.
Mais si l'autre roi
qui vient décide
d'aller vers les idoles,
Israël aussi suit ce roi
dans les idoles.
C'était un mouvement cyclique
et à cause de ça,
Israël péchait
et Dieu manifestait
des châtiments temporaires
parce que Dieu,
à un moment,
les rétablissait par sa grâce.
Il y avait toujours
la grâce de Dieu
qui agissait par la suite
pour le pardon
et la restauration.
Et quelque part,
Israël,
il s'était habitué à ça.
Il s'était habitué
à toujours espérer
ainsi que Dieu les délivre.
Et d'ailleurs,
même,
un des épisodes
les plus marquants
là-dessus,
c'est,
vous voyez,
quand,
à un moment,
ils se sont détournés
de l'éternel
et dans le livre
de Samuel,
à un moment,
ils vont à la guerre
sans l'arche
de l'alliance
de l'éternel.
Et quand les philistins
sont en train de les battre,
ils vont dire à un moment,
c'est parce que l'arche
de l'alliance n'est pas.
Allons chercher l'arche
de l'alliance
et on va gagner.
Et donc là,
ils savaient,
donc ils savaient à un moment
ce qu'il fallait faire.
Mais là,
Dieu décide même
de livrer l'arche
de l'alliance
aux mains des philistins
parce qu'il dit à un moment,
il délivrera d'une autre façon.
Donc Dieu avait manifesté
sa patience
pendant plusieurs siècles
envers Israël.
Mais un moment,
et c'est important
de le souligner,
même dans la manifestation
de sa colère
pour le bien d'Israël,
pour le bien
des nations alentours,
Dieu ne pouvait plus
ignorer
et il devait juger.
Ce que nous avons
comme enseignement
quand nous regardons
ce premier point,
nous regardons
ce deuxième point
qui nous parle justement
de pourquoi
ces jugements
a été sévères,
c'est parce qu'à un moment,
Israël n'a pas réalisé
la grâce qu'ils avaient
d'avoir l'éternel
pour Dieu.
Ils ont pris
la patience de Dieu,
ils ont pris
la miséricorde de Dieu,
les bénédictions de Dieu
pour des choses acquises.
Et à un moment,
même dans leur compréhension,
quand vous lisez
les textes,
vous allez remarquer
à un moment
que dans leur plainte,
ils se disent à un moment,
mais comment Dieu
peut livrer
Jérusalem aux païens ?
Pour eux,
c'est qu'ils pouvaient
être dans ce cycle
de péché,
de restauration,
de toute façon,
Dieu n'allait jamais
les enlever
de cette terre promise
qu'il leur avait donnée.
Mais à un moment,
Dieu leur manifeste
le fait,
à un moment,
ces choses
qu'ils avaient prises
pour acquises,
il allait leur enlever
ces choses-là.
Ils avaient pris
sa patience,
sa miséricorde
pour acquises,
il allait les enlever.
Et comme je vous disais
à un moment,
nous ne sommes pas
différents d'Israël
à un moment
par rapport à nos attitudes
dans nos vies.
Une des leçons
que nous devons retenir
aussi en voyant
ces jugements pénibles
et sévères de Dieu,
c'est de voir aussi
lorsque nous sommes
dans cette négligence
de prendre la grâce
de Dieu
pour acquise.
Ou à un moment,
nous allons être
dans le péché,
dans un péché constant
parce que,
de toute façon,
Dieu manifeste sa grâce.
C'est même
le leitmotiv
de beaucoup
dans certaines églises
de se dire
à un moment
que dès qu'on est sauvé,
on peut continuer
à péché
parce que,
d'une certaine façon,
il suffit
qu'on aille dimanche
à l'église
et qu'on demande pardon
à Dieu.
Souvent,
on ne demande même
plus pardon à Dieu.
Il suffit juste
qu'on aille à l'église,
Dieu se souviendra de nous.
Mais,
là encore,
dans Hébreu,
une exhortation
en lien
avec le fait
de mettre nos gueurs
en garde
contre cette négligence.
Hébreu nous dit
à un moment
que nous devons être sûrs
de nous attacher
aux choses
que nous avons entendues,
de peur que nous soyons
emportés loin d'elles.
Ne prenons pas
ces choses pour acquises
parce que,
lorsque le jugement
de Dieu s'abat,
cette miséricorde,
cette grâce
sur laquelle on comptait,
elle disparaisse.
Cette paix
qu'on pouvait avoir,
elle disparaît.
Ce don de la repentance,
nous,
souvent,
nous pouvons prendre
pour acquis
le don de la repentance.
La repentance
est un don.
Et chaque fois
que tu as la grâce
de pouvoir demander
pardon à Dieu
pour quelque chose
que tu as fait de mal,
tu dois remercier
le Seigneur
pour le cœur
qu'il te donne
d'être sensible au péché.
Mais à un moment,
la repentance,
le don de la repentance
s'enlève de cœur
de certaines personnes
et elle ne demande
même plus pardon à Dieu.
Et donc,
à un moment,
dans le bruit,
il nous a dit
que nous devons
nous attacher
à ces choses
que nous avons entendues,
de peur que nous
nous soyons emportés loin d'elle.
Car si la parole annoncée
par des anges
a eu son effet
et si toute transgression
et toute désobéissance
a reçu une juste rétribution,
comme nous sommes en train
de le voir dans Ézéchiel,
comment échapperons-nous
en négligeant
un si grand salut
qui, annoncé d'abord
par le Seigneur,
nous a été confirmé
par ceux qui l'ont entendu,
Dieu appuyant
leurs témoignages
par des signes,
des prodiges
et divers miracles
et par les dons
du Saint-Esprit
distribué selon sa volonté.
Hébreu 2, versets 1 à 4.
Le souci d'Israël,
et voilà pourquoi
les jugements de Dieu
ont été sévères et pénibles,
c'est que plusieurs fois
le désir d'Israël
a été de se conformer
à ce qu'il voyait
dans les autres nations
plutôt que d'être
la lumière de ces nations.
Leur désir a été
à un moment
d'aimer
ce qu'ils voyaient
dans ces nations,
de ne pas considérer
le fait que Dieu
était leur Dieu.
Ils ont aimé ces choses,
il n'y avait pas
l'amour de Dieu
en eux
et à cause
de cette convoitise
de la chair,
à cause de toutes ces choses,
le jugement de Dieu
s'est abattu sur eux.
Et là encore,
c'est pour nous
un rappel aussi
quand Dieu nous appelle
aussi dans notre
considération aussi.
Lorsque nous,
en tant qu'Église,
nous sommes en train
d'être aussi dans ce désir
et souvent nous nous donnons
une fausse excuse,
nous allons dire
un moment,
c'est pour essayer
d'attirer ceux
qui ne connaissent pas Dieu.
On essaye d'apporter
le monde dans l'Église
pour que le monde
soit sauvé.
Finalement,
ce qui se passe,
c'est le même schéma
qu'Israël a eu.
Israël a apporté
le péché des nations
au milieu d'eux
et le jugement
de Dieu est arrivé.
Et pour n'importe
quelle Église
qui est en train
d'agir avec ce même schéma,
ce sera la même chose.
N'importe quelle Église
qui laisse entrer
le monde,
le divertissement,
parce qu'à un moment,
on m'a dit,
il faut divertir les personnes
afin qu'elles puissent
rester dans l'Église.
À la fin,
tu vas t'épuiser
et tu vas finir par mourir.
C'est une Église
qui va finir par mourir.
Parce que quand les gens
n'auront plus
le divertissement
dont ils ont besoin,
ils partiront ailleurs.
Et donc,
nous avons beaucoup
de croyants
qui n'ont plus
cette considération
à un moment
de cet aspect évangélique.
Israël,
Dieu dit à un moment
à Israël
qu'ils étaient là
pour être lumière des nations.
Ils étaient là
non pour se conformer
aux nations,
mais pour donner
un modèle aux nations.
C'est ce que nous avons lu
dans le Deutéronome.
Mais à un moment,
ils sont allés
dans l'autre sens.
Ils ont voulu
se conformer plutôt
à ces nations
et suivre le modèle
des nations.
Et aussi,
dans cet aspect,
aujourd'hui,
au lieu d'être
lumière des nations,
ils ont finalement
été dans les ténèbres
de ces nations.
Et aujourd'hui,
même encore,
nous allons trouver
beaucoup de croyants
qui ne vont plus
avoir de considération
pour l'aspect évangélique
de notre appel.
À un moment,
ils considèrent
qu'ils sont sauvés
et qu'ils vont vivre
leur foi en petit comité.
Ils n'ont pas besoin
de déranger les gens
parce que leur foi
doit être une foi
personnelle à vivre.
Il ne faut pas
qu'ils dérangent
les gens
avec certains aspects
difficiles de l'évangile.
Et ils laissent
à d'autres
le soin
d'annoncer l'évangile.
D'ailleurs,
ils vont être contents
quand ils entendent
« Ah, il y a un missionnaire
dans quel pays ? »
« Ah, j'admire son courage
qu'il soit missionnaire.
Ça, c'est admirable
parce que moi,
je ne pourrais pas. »
Et pourtant,
nous sommes tous missionnaires.
De là où nous sommes,
nous sommes tous appelés
à pouvoir porter
cet évangile.
Israël a retenu la vérité.
Ils ont retenu la vérité
qu'ils auraient dû donner
aux nations.
Ils ont retenu la vérité
qu'ils auraient dû afficher
dans leur adoration,
dans leur mode de vie.
Et voilà pourquoi
les jugements de Dieu
ont été sévères
et pénibles.
Voilà pourquoi Dieu parle
même d'un jugement
encore plus sévère
que celui de Sodome.
Et voilà pourquoi aussi,
pour nous aussi,
par rapport à cet aspect
d'Israël aussi,
dans cette considération,
nous devons voir
la nécessité pour nous aussi
d'annoncer l'évangile.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est ce principe,
un moment,
de dire un moment
que l'évangile
est trop confrontatif.
Alors, je vais éviter
d'être confrontatif.
Je vais éviter
d'être dans la vérité.
Vous voyez qu'un moment,
Dieu dit à un moment
que si Israël était
en train d'annoncer la vérité,
même si ça troublait
les nations,
c'était un acte d'amour.
Voilà pourquoi
il les avait placés
au milieu des nations,
pour qu'ils annoncent
cette vérité,
même si c'était
une vérité dérangeante,
de dire à un moment
que toutes les idoles,
tout le panthéon de Dieu
que vous avez,
ce ne sont que des idoles
de bois et de pierre.
Mais nous,
nous servons le Dieu vrai,
le Dieu unique.
Aujourd'hui,
si vous allez
sur un réseau social
ou vous allez dans la rue
et vous dites aux personnes
tous les dieux
en qui vous croyez,
ce ne sont que des dieux
de votre propre imagination.
Le Dieu qui a créé
le ciel et la terre
et qui est unique
et le seul vrai Dieu.
Et si vous dites
un moment,
Jésus-Christ est le seul chemin,
la vérité et la vie,
aujourd'hui,
avec les principes
des vérités relatives,
vous êtes parti
pour de bons débats.
Si bien sûr,
quelqu'un ne vous tape
même pas,
parce que maintenant,
ça devient autre chose.
Mais Paul dit à un moment,
si j'annonce l'Évangile,
ce n'est pas pour moi
un sujet de gloire
qu'à la nécessité
m'en est imposée.
Israël,
à un moment,
ne voyait plus cette nécessité.
Il dit,
malheur à moi
si je n'annonce pas l'Évangile.
Si je le fais de bon cœur,
j'en ai la récompense.
Mais si je le fais malgré moi,
c'est une charge
qui m'est confiée.
Et là,
nous voyons à un moment
que le problème d'Israël,
c'est que maintenant,
il le faisait malgré eux.
C'est-à-dire à un moment
que quand il y a un roi
qui sert l'Éternel,
qui leur a montré le chemin
et qui meurt
et que tout le peuple
se détourne à la mort du roi,
nous voyons à un moment
que ce n'est pas quelque chose
qu'il faisait de bon cœur.
On voit à un moment
qu'il y avait quelque chose
dans la masse
du peuple d'Israël
qui n'était pas réglé
dans leur amour pour Dieu.
Ils n'avaient pas
l'amour de Dieu.
Ils avaient besoin
d'une transformation.
Et c'est là où je parle
à un moment de ce sens
où Dieu était en train
de nous montrer
la nécessité,
le besoin de Christ
au travers de l'échec d'Israël
à pouvoir respecter
la loi de Dieu.
Et donc,
nous,
nous devons considérer
à un moment
si pour toi
annoncer l'évangile,
c'est une charge lourde
qui t'est confiée,
tu as besoin
de revoir tes priorités.
Ça veut dire à un moment
que tu es maintenant
parti dans une considération
de plutôt te conformer
au monde
plutôt que d'annoncer
la vérité de l'évangile.
Et là,
comme je vous dis à un moment,
le critère d'amour de Dieu,
c'était
qu'Israël affiche
sa gloire,
Israël affiche
sa loi.
Le critère d'amour de Dieu,
c'est que nous puissions
annoncer la vérité
de l'évangile
dans notre façon
d'adorer Dieu,
dans nos modes de vie.
Mais si nous fermons
les yeux
sur certaines choses
qui peuvent même
être considérées
comme des abominations,
et c'était là
le problème d'Israël
à un moment,
c'était là
le problème d'Israël
à un moment,
nous sommes en train
d'appeler un jugement
de Dieu,
une colère de Dieu
sur notre vie.
Et je voudrais rajouter
un point
en parlant justement
de cet aspect
de pourquoi ce jugement,
parce que même aujourd'hui,
sur certains aspects,
on a,
les personnes ont du mal,
et c'est cet aspect
de pouvoir être corrigé,
parce que nous voyons
au moment que Dieu
corrige son peuple.
Aujourd'hui,
beaucoup de personnes
vont refuser la correction.
Vous voyez,
des personnes qui vont dire
à un moment,
je n'ai pas besoin
qu'on me rappelle
telle ou telle chose.
Aujourd'hui,
il y a des personnes
qui prennent pratiquement,
c'est comme si vous leur avez
planté un couteau dans le cœur
quand son père ou sa mère
va lui dire,
mais moi,
j'aurais espéré
que tu sois marié aujourd'hui,
tu n'es toujours pas marié.
Il va dire à un moment,
mais de quel droit
tu te permets de...
Aujourd'hui,
on est dans une situation
où les personnes
ne veulent plus être corrigées.
Elles n'arrivent pas
à accepter cette idée
que Dieu puisse se juger.
Mais lorsque nous annonçons
l'Évangile,
un peu dans ce que nous avons lu
de Jean 3,
nous devons annoncer
que Dieu est amour
pour avoir envoyé son Fils,
afin que quiconque croit
en lui ne périsse point,
mais que Dieu sera juste
dans ses jugements
pour que ceux
qui n'ont pas cru
au Fils soient jugés.
Et ce qui nous amène
sur le troisième point,
qui est aussi très important,
ce troisième point,
c'est ce que nous avons lu
à cause de toutes
tes abominations.
Alors, dans certaines versions,
on a plutôt
je te ferai ce que je n'ai
pas encore fait,
ce que je ne ferai jamais
à cause de toutes
tes abominations.
Ici, dans la version
que j'ai,
il commence par ça,
mais plutôt dans la préparation,
c'était plutôt
à cause de toutes
tes abominations.
Donc, Dieu, à un moment,
dit, les jugements
seront sévères,
les jugements seront pénibles
parce qu'Israël
a choisi de se conformer
aux nations.
Israël a refusé
de suivre l'Éternel,
d'être un modèle
pour les nations.
Et Israël l'a fait aussi
et à cause
de toutes ces abominations.
Une chose qui est frappante
lorsque nous lisons le livre,
même quand vous allez lire
Jérémie et Ézéchiel,
là, Ézéchiel,
quand nous lisons Ézéchiel,
il va avoir
un ministère difficile
parce que le peuple
est déporté
et il n'arrive pas
à accepter
ce qu'il est en train
de leur dire.
Mais pour Jérémie,
ce sera même encore pire.
C'est-à-dire que Jérémie
est avec le peuple
qui est assiégé
par Babylone
et malgré tout
ce qu'il leur avait dit
avant même le siège
de Babylone,
il refuse de se repentir.
Et au contraire,
on voit un moment
qu'il se sent
dans le déni
alors que ces choses
avaient été avancées
bien à l'avance
et même les nations
autour connaissaient
les jugements
qui avaient été prononcés
par Jérémie.
Lorsque Babylone rentre,
lorsque les babyloniens
vont prendre Jérusalem,
la seule personne
qui est autorisée
à aller où elle veut,
ce sera Jérémie.
Parce qu'à un moment,
ils vont lui dire
nous avons entendu
tout ce que tu disais
depuis à ce peuple
en les appelant
à se repentir.
Ils ne se sont pas repentis.
Il était le seul
qui avait le droit
d'aller où il voulait.
Et ils étaient
dans le déni.
Alors que même
lorsque Jérémie
annonçait ces choses
bien à l'avance,
lorsque ces choses
voient leur manifestation,
les dirigeants
du peuple,
les dirigeants royaux
et spirituels
ont toujours
cette raideur de coups
à refuser
de se repentir
et à s'entêter
dans la rébellion.
Dieu est en train
de juger
l'adultère spirituelle
d'Israël.
Le problème
n'était pas
parce que vous voyez,
on peut chercher
à comprendre
en se disant
un moment,
mais Babylone
décidait juste
d'envahir.
Non,
le problème
n'était pas
un problème
géopolitique.
Le problème
était un problème
spirituel.
Israël était
une petite nation
et pendant des siècles,
Dieu a préservé
Israël
de tous les grands
empires autour.
Et si Dieu
permet maintenant
que Nebuchadnezzar
soit en train
d'arriver à ses fins,
c'est parce que
c'était un problème
spirituel.
C'était à cause
de l'adultère d'Israël.
Israël avait
non seulement
commis
un adultère spirituel,
mais en plus,
ils avaient ouvert
la porte
à des péchés,
à des abominations
que Dieu leur avait
formellement interdites.
À travers le culte
qu'ils avaient pris
d'autres nations,
ils avaient commencé
à pratiquer
les sacrifices humains,
ils avaient généralisé
l'immoralité sexuelle,
notamment dans des pratiques
cérémonielles.
Et quand nous lisons même,
je veux vous dire,
par exemple,
lisez beaucoup
les petits prophètes,
entre guillemets,
qu'on appelle
les petits prophètes,
vous allez voir
comment ils dénoncent
l'injustice
de ceux
qui étaient au pouvoir
vis-à-vis des plus petits.
Et donc,
il y avait une injustice
qu'Israël n'avait pas connue
à cause de ce culte
des idoles.
Et donc,
même déportés
à Babylone,
ils ne voyaient pas
ce qu'ils avaient fait
de mal
pour en arriver là.
Ils avaient les signes
extérieurs de la religion
parce que s'ils avaient été
dans la compréhension,
s'ils avaient été vraiment
dans la soumission
à la parole de Dieu,
ils auraient compris
comme certains l'ont fait.
C'est-à-dire que quand
Daniel ou Ézéchiel
vont intercéder,
ils vont revenir
à cette alliance
qui avait été établie
dans le Théronome
en disant
« Nous avons violé
tous les points
de cette alliance
et voilà pourquoi
tu es juste
dans tes jugements. »
Mais là,
ils avaient les signes
extérieurs de la religion,
mais la parole de Dieu
n'était plus dans les cœurs.
La parole de Dieu
n'avait plus été enseignée
au peuple
comme il se devait
et le peuple
n'arrivait pas à réaliser
que c'était à cause
de leur péché
qu'ils avaient été
conduits à Babylone.
Au contraire,
il y a même certains
qui espéraient pouvoir
partir rapidement
de Babylone.
Ils pensaient même
parce que ce qui se passait
à l'époque,
c'est que quand
les Bucanézar
envahit toute la région,
le pharaon d'Égypte,
lui,
il décide de,
comme c'était
les deux puissances régionales,
le pharaon d'Égypte.
Vous le lisez même
quand vous lisez Jérémie,
vous voyez un moment
que Cédéciasse
va faire appel
au pharaon d'Égypte
pour venir le soutenir.
Et donc,
quand le pharaon
vient une première fois,
Nébuchanézar se retire.
Donc,
Nébuchanézar
a fait deux sièges
de Jérusalem.
Il fait un premier siège
et quand le pharaon arrive,
il se replie d'abord.
Et donc là,
ils se disent à un moment,
tout ce que Jérémie
nous a dit,
on n'y croit pas.
Donc là,
ils sont réconfortés
en disant à un moment,
Jérémie nous a menti,
nous n'avons plus à craindre.
Mais Jérémie leur dit
à un moment,
non,
Nébuchanézar reviendra
parce que
vos péchés sont là
et vous refusez
de vous repentir.
Jérusalem sera détruite.
Et même là,
vous voyez,
Dieu,
dans la manifestation
de ses jugements,
Dieu leur donne
même encore une grâce.
Avant de détruire Jérusalem,
il permet même encore
que Nébuchanézar se retire
et qu'il puisse se repentir.
Mais il décide
de rester dans le péché.
Au contraire,
lorsque Nébuchanézar revienne,
ils ont même encore
cette assurance
que Pharaon va réussir
à le vaincre.
Sauf que cette fois-ci,
Nébuchanézar va vaincre
le Pharaon
et il va arriver
jusqu'en Égypte.
L'idolâtrie
dans laquelle ils étaient,
avaient cautérisé
leur conscience.
Et d'ailleurs,
voilà pourquoi,
quand vous allez lire aujourd'hui,
c'est un des passages
de la Bible
qui est beaucoup déformé.
Lorsque Jérémie envoie
cette lettre
en leur disant,
au moment,
pour ceux qui sont déportés,
baptissez à Babylone,
voilà,
multipliez-vous.
Il leur dit,
au moment,
ne comptez pas revenir.
Mais,
le péché avait tellement
cautérisé leur conscience
qu'ils n'arrivaient
même plus à distinguer
le mal du bien.
Ils n'arrivaient même plus
à reconnaître
en quoi ils avaient péché
contre l'Éternel.
Là,
Dieu est en train
d'utiliser ces prophètes
pour leur dire,
si vous êtes dans cette situation,
c'est parce que vous avez péché.
Si ma colère se manifeste,
c'est à cause de ça.
Mais ils n'arrivaient même plus
à reconnaître.
Ils étaient étonnés
en quelque sorte
de la colère de Dieu
qui était annoncée
par les prophètes.
Et,
une des responsabilités
qui venaient là-dessus,
c'était à cause
des bergers de ce peuple.
À un moment,
Dieu va même parler
dans Ézéchiel,
chapitre 34,
il va parler de ce,
de,
il va parler de ces bergers
qui auraient dû servir le peuple,
ces personnes
qui auraient dû
prodiquer les soins,
rappeler,
qu'est-ce que la loi
de l'Éternel disait
qui aurait dû amener
les personnes à la repentance,
les leaders spirituels
et même politiques
ont au contraire
choisi d'abuser d'eux
pour pouvoir préserver
leurs avantages.
Ils les ont gouvernés
dans l'injustice,
ils les ont trompés,
ils les ont encouragés
dans ces pratiques immorales.
Et,
vous voyez,
Ézéchiel,
au chapitre 34,
rappelle le jugement
qui sera le leur.
Et lorsque nous arrivons
dans Jérémie 52,
nous voyons un moment
que le jugement
qui va apparaître,
c'est-à-dire
quand Nebuchadnezzar
prend Jérusalem,
une des premières choses
qu'ils vont faire,
c'est de réunir
tous les sacrificateurs,
les hauts sacrificateurs,
le clergé,
et ils ne vont pas
les emmener en exil,
ils vont les exécuter,
ils vont tous les tuer.
Parce qu'à un moment,
le jugement de Dieu
s'exerce sur ces personnes
qui auraient dû
dire la vérité au peuple
et qui ne l'ont pas dit,
ces personnes
qui auraient dû
rappeler au peuple
que c'était à cause
du péché
qu'ils étaient là
et ils ne l'ont pas fait.
Mais au contraire,
ils les ont encouragés
à continuer
à croire dans des chimères,
ils les ont encouragés
à dire à un moment
que leur espérance,
c'était dans ce que
l'Égypte allait faire
ou dans d'autres moyens.
et le jugement,
si nous voyons un jugement
de Dieu qui s'est exécuté
vis-à-vis
de ces faux bergers,
nous devons croire aussi
qu'aujourd'hui,
le jugement de Dieu
s'exercera aussi
contre ceux
qui ne guident pas
le peuple correctement,
ceux qui inversent
les choses,
ceux qui appellent
bien mal
et ceux qui appellent
mal bien.
Aujourd'hui,
dans beaucoup d'églises,
même, on va dire à un moment,
il y a beaucoup
qui n'ont même pas entendu
parler de ce principe
de la colère de Dieu
parce qu'on va dire à un moment,
il ne faut pas frustrer les gens,
il ne faut pas leur parler
de la colère de Dieu,
il faut juste leur dire
que Dieu est amour
et qu'il veut juste
leur paix.
Mais comme je vous ai dit
à un moment,
pour que nous puissions
avoir la paix de Dieu,
il faut
qu'il y ait d'abord justice.
Et pour qu'il y ait justice,
il faut qu'il y ait
notre repentance.
et la justice vient
avec ce que
le Fils de Dieu
accomplit pour nous.
Et quand nous plaçons
notre confiance
dans ce que le Fils de Dieu
accomplit pour nous,
alors c'est alors
que nous pouvons échapper
à la colère de Dieu
à venir.
Aujourd'hui,
les nations,
en tant que telles,
nous pouvons vivre,
nous allons vivre,
nous vivons,
dans les diverses nations,
nous sommes en train
de vivre des jugements
temporaires de Dieu.
Nous sommes en train
de voir un moment,
les nations vendent
dans le péché,
la patience de Dieu
arrive à une certaine limite,
les nations sont frappées
par rapport aux conséquences
de leur péché.
Mais la Bible nous parle
d'un jour de colère
de l'éternel
qui sera un jour
définitif de jugement.
Donc,
en rejetant Dieu,
en rejetant ses lois
et ses ordonnances,
Israël a inversé,
donc voilà pourquoi
il parle,
à cause de toutes
les abominations,
Israël a inversé
son échelle de valeur.
Ils ont dilué
l'importance du péché.
Pour eux,
ils n'ont plus été
dans la considération
de ce qu'a été le péché.
Ils n'arrivaient même
plus à reconnaître
ce qui était un péché
aux yeux de Dieu.
Ils considéraient maintenant
comme normal et juste
ces péchés que Dieu
condamnait dans sa parole.
Et vous allez même voir
quand vous lisez
le livre d'Ézéchiel
à un moment,
Ézéchiel va être conduit
en vision jusqu'à Jérusalem
pour voir ce que
les sacrificateurs faisaient
même dans le temple.
Comment ?
Même dans le temple
de l'Éternel.
Et voilà pourquoi
à un moment,
nous avons lu
dans le verset 11,
il dit,
c'est pourquoi je suis vivant,
dit le Seigneur l'Éternel,
parce que tu as souillé
mon sanctuaire
par toutes tes idoles
et toutes tes abominations.
Ézéchiel n'avait pas réalisé,
mais à un moment,
Dieu le conduit en esprit
jusqu'à Jérusalem.
Ézéchiel voit même
les principaux sacrificateurs
du peuple
qui ont placé
les idoles
dans le temple
et qui adorent
des dieux
de pierre
et de fer
dans le temple de Dieu.
Ils ont souillé
le temple de Dieu.
Ils avaient perdu
cette notion,
ils n'avaient même plus
cette compréhension
de ce qui est mal
ou ce qui est bien
aux yeux de l'Éternel.
Et notre prière
par rapport à ça,
que notre Dieu
garde nos cœurs
pour nous,
par rapport
à toutes ces abominations,
que notre Dieu
garde notre cœur
de trouver
normal
ses péchés.
Ce que Dieu
considère comme péché,
que Dieu garde nos cœurs
de trouver cela
comme étant des choses
normales,
comme des choses
justes.
Nos prières,
et je vais dire
ma prière pour chacun
de nous,
c'est que Dieu garde nos cœurs
de nous poser en victime
du moindre péché.
Parce qu'à un moment,
Israël
trouvait des excuses
à son péché à un moment.
Il ne voyait pas
que c'était des abominations.
Il trouvait
que c'était juste
parce qu'il s'était conformé
à ce que les autres nations
faisaient.
Donc,
il trouvait juste
de pouvoir vivre ces choses.
Comme on va trouver
juste un moment d'excuser,
on va dire un moment,
si je vis ces choses,
ce n'est pas ma faute,
c'est familial.
Si je suis sanguin,
si je me mets en colère,
dans une colère
qui est incontrôlable,
c'est parce que,
je ne sais pas
si c'est les Italiens
qui se fâchent comme ça,
mais parce que je suis Italien,
donc voilà.
Je sais qu'à un moment,
souvent certains le disent,
je suis Camerounais,
les Camerounais,
il y avait une amie
qui est revenue du Camerounais
qui dit,
mais les Camerounais,
ils sont très nerveux.
Et souvent,
ils vont dire,
non, c'est normal,
nous Camerounais,
nous sommes nerveux.
Non.
Si tu es croyant,
tu ne dois pas oublier
que Dieu te rappelle
que tu es une nouvelle créature.
Et en aucun cas,
tu ne dois trouver
une excuse
à ton péché.
Et qu'est-ce que
la parole de Dieu nous dit
pour que justement,
nous n'ayons pas
cette considération
d'inverser les choses
que nous ne soyons pas
sur le jugement d'Israël,
c'était du fait
que ce que Dieu considérait
comme abomination,
il ne le considérait
plus comme une abomination.
Voilà ce que
la parole de Dieu nous dit
dans 1 Jean,
au verset 8 à 10.
Jean va nous dire,
et c'est un bon moyen
pour nous de garder
nos cœurs du déni
ou de la moindre
excuse au péché,
il dit,
mais si nous marchons
dans la lumière,
comme il est lui-même
nous sommes mutuellement
en communion
et le sang de Jésus,
son fils,
nous purifie
de tout péché.
Si nous disons
que nous n'avons pas
de péché,
nous nous séduisons
nous-mêmes
et la vérité
n'est point en nous.
Si nous confessons
nos péchés,
il est fidèle
et juste
pour nous les pardonner
et pour nous purifier
de toute iniquité.
Si nous disons
que nous n'avons pas péché,
nous le faisons menteur
et sa parole
est point en nous.
Comment nous gardons
nos cœurs ?
Le problème d'Israël,
Dieu dit à un moment,
mes jugements seront sévères
et pénibles
parce qu'Israël
a oublié le rôle
que Dieu lui avait donné.
Mais à un moment,
il dit,
il rappelle à un moment
qu'il fera des choses
telles qu'ils n'ont jamais
entendu à cause
des abominations.
Israël avait inversé.
Ce qui était des abominations
était devenu des choses
juste pour eux.
Mais pour nous,
si nous marchons
dans la lumière,
ça veut dire que
si nous laissons
nos cœurs,
si nous laissons nos vies
être toujours éclairés
par la parole de Dieu,
ça dit qu'il n'y a pas
quelque chose
que nous cachons,
il n'y a pas une relation
que nous allons cacher
où on ne peut même
pas parler à Dieu
parce que nous savons
que cette relation
que nous sommes en train
d'entretenir
n'est pas en train
de le glorifier.
Nos frères et sœurs
en Christ ne le connaissent pas
parce que nous savons
que si j'en parle
à mes frères et sœurs,
ils vont même me dire
mon frère,
tu es peut-être en train
d'aller dans une voie
qui n'est pas bonne.
C'est ça,
ces ténèbres
dont la parole de Dieu parle.
Mais nous devons toujours
marcher dans la lumière,
laisser que la parole de Dieu
soit en train d'éclairer
chaque aspect de notre vie,
alors nous serons
mutuellement en communion
et le sang de Christ
nous purifiera.
Israël,
lorsqu'ils sont en train
de vivre la colère de Dieu,
ils sont en train
de vivre le jument de Dieu,
de se séduire en disant
nous ne voyons pas
en quoi nous avons péché.
Nous ne voyons pas
en quoi il serait justifié
que Dieu soit en train
de nous juger.
ça c'était le déni.
Mais nous avons besoin
un moment de reconnaître
un moment que
nous sommes pécheurs.
La grâce de Dieu
s'exerce en nous,
donc nous ne péchons
plus activement
comme ceux qui ne connaissent
pas Dieu le feraient.
Mais nous sommes conscients
un moment que chaque jour
la grâce de Dieu est là
parce qu'il nous arrive
de pécher.
Et si nous confessons
nos péchés,
il est fidèle et juste
pour nous les pardonner.
Et ce que Dieu a fait
dans sa grâce
quand il lève
Ézéchiel en intercesseur,
c'est pour que même
si le peuple est dans
le déni,
voyons la grâce de Dieu,
Dieu lève des intercesseurs.
Ézéchiel va intercéder.
Ézéchiel va dire
Seigneur pardonne
à ton peuple
même s'ils ne reconnaissent
pas leur péché.
Pardonne.
Nous, nous nous posons
en intercesseur
et nous disons
nous reconnaissons
que nous avons péché.
Pardonne à ce peuple.
C'est ce que Ézéchiel a fait.
C'est ce que Daniel a fait.
Et donc, pour conclure,
bien que les jugements
de Dieu
soient sévères
et pénibles,
bien que les jugements
de Dieu
qui sont annoncés
sur Jérusalem,
nous avons lu
une partie
de ces jugements
qui sont assez durs
et comme je vous ai dit,
ce sont des choses
qui sont arrivées
de façon littérale
et là,
ce n'est qu'une partie,
vraiment une petite partie
de voir comment
des mères
ont mangé
leurs nourrissons
qui étaient morts.
La parole de Dieu
nous dit à un moment
que les jugements
qui sont annoncés
par Dieu
étaient pleinement justifiés.
C'est important pour nous
avant de nous permettre
de juger l'œuvre de Dieu,
de garder nos cœurs
et de considérer
à un moment
que la colère
de l'Éternel,
les jugements
de l'Éternel
sont toujours justes
et sains.
Et nous avons besoin
de ça
parce que souvent,
nous allons toujours
rabaisser Dieu
à notre niveau.
Nous allons considérer Dieu
en fonction aussi
de nos considérations.
nous savons
au moment
que nos colères
ne sont pas toujours justes.
Nous savons au moment
que nos colères
ne sont pas toujours justifiées
et nous espérons
au moment
que Dieu soit
dans ce même cas de figure.
Mais Dieu n'est pas
touché par le péché.
La colère de Dieu
est une chose redoutable
et la colère de Dieu
se manifestera toujours.
Là, je le dis,
même quand les hommes
pensent que Dieu
ne voit pas le mal,
même quand les hommes
pensent qu'il y a peut-être
un Dieu
mais qu'il est incapable
de juger le mal,
la colère de Dieu
se manifestera
toujours du ciel
contre toute forme
d'impiété
et d'injustice.
Et nous l'avons lu
au début
de la prédication,
dans l'intro
de notre culte,
lorsque nous l'avons lu
dans Esaïe 26,
les hommes
peuvent penser
à un moment
que Dieu ne juge pas,
les hommes peuvent penser
à un moment
que Dieu ne voit pas,
mais Dieu voit tout
et Dieu rendra
à chacun
selon ses œuvres.
mais pour ceux
qui ont compris
leur misère spirituelle,
pour ceux qui ont placé
leur salut
et leur justification
dans le sang
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
comme je l'ai dit,
nous allons comprendre
au moment
que nous serons épargnés
de cette colère.
Nous sommes même épargnés
Voilà pourquoi,
même au milieu
des tribulations
de ce monde,
lorsque,
tout à l'heure,
nous étions en train
de chanter,
quand nous avons fini
la répétition,
nous avons chanté
un chant,
ça s'appelle
« Tisse au suite »
et l'histoire
de ce chant,
c'est une sœur
qui avait émigré
de l'Angleterre
aux États-Unis
avec sa famille.
Donc,
ils avaient deux enfants,
un fils et une fille
et ils sont allés
pique-niquer une fois,
ils sont allés pique-niquer
au bord d'une rivière
et pendant qu'ils faisaient
la sieste,
l'enfant est allé
dans l'eau,
le garçon est allé
le père a essayé
de le sauver,
les deux se sont noyés.
Et c'est incompréhensible
de voir comment
cette femme,
comment Dieu
a pu donner la paix
à cette sœur
même dans la façon
dont elle a été éprouvée.
Dieu a pourvu.
À un moment,
sans même qu'elle
ait demandé,
il y a des personnes
qui sont venues
qui ont laissé
des paniers d'habits,
de nourriture
à la porte de sa maison
parce qu'à l'époque,
elle ne travaillait pas,
c'est le mari qui travaille
toutes ces choses.
Et comment Dieu pourvoyait ?
Elle a écrit ce chant
et quand vous lisez
les paroles de ce chant,
vous allez vous dire
à un moment
que c'est quelqu'un
qui était dans la joie,
quelqu'un qui expérimentait
les bénédictions de Dieu,
peut-être que Dieu
lui avait donné quelque chose
et puis il était tellement
content qu'il a écrit
que c'est si doux
de croire en Jésus.
Mais là,
c'était une femme
qui avait perdu son mari
et son enfant noyé
et qui dit à un moment
que c'est si doux
de croire en Jésus.
Et donc,
pour nous qui comprenons
notre misère spirituelle,
même au milieu d'un monde
qui est jugé
par la colère de Dieu,
à cause de leur péché
et la colère de Dieu
qui s'abat,
nous pourrons toujours
trouver la paix de Dieu.
Et cette conclusion
dans Romains,
nous allons finir là,
c'est dans Romains,
voilà ce que Paul nous dit
à un moment
qui doit aussi nous encourager
lorsque nous voyons
ces choses,
même par rapport
à ces manifestations
de jugement,
d'être au repos,
mais d'être en train
d'intercéder,
c'est-à-dire notre rôle,
contrairement à Israël,
c'est d'être des lumières
pour les nations.
Notre rôle,
c'est de faire
ce qu'Ézéchiel a fait.
Ézéchiel s'est posé
en intercesseur.
Nous devons aussi être
des intercesseurs
pour les nations
dans lesquelles Dieu
nous a placés.
Et Paul dit,
à plus forte raison donc,
maintenant que nous sommes
justifiés par son sang,
serons-nous sauvés
par lui de la colère.
Car si lorsque nous étions
ennemis,
nous avons été réconciliés
avec Dieu
par la mort de son fils,
à plus forte raison,
étant réconciliés,
serons-nous sauvés
par sa vie.
Et non seulement cela,
mais encore,
nous nous glorifions en Dieu
par notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
par qui maintenant
nous avons obtenu
la réconciliation.
Amen.
Sous-titrage Société Radio-Canada